there was a sense of normality today but
one which could come with serious
repercussions a week on from the relaxed
lockdown measures the hot weather cool
drinks and ice creams in Brighton were
just too tempting
there's actually that especially with
the weather what happened I fall out to
make the most of its calm outside
enjoy yourself obviously just respect
the government so far so just keep the
chiminea distance weapons gorgeous and a
lot of places are open then away from
everyone I cannot see them any
difference in me go that part next by us
it's a big open area so I think all ok
it's outside the famous pier maybe shut
but this city's beach is open it's an
escape for many after weeks of stringent
lockdown rules but the council here are
telling people to stay away I'm telling
people not to come really to make sure
that are they and everybody else stay
safe so that's the only reason why I'm
telling people not to come so the Prime
Minister's that is fine you can come as
long as your social distance yes but you
city council we are saying to people
stay safe please don't come because
we're not going to be able to guarantee
your safety if you can't socially
distance but it wasn't just the South
Coast basking in the sunshine the whole
of the country experienced the heat in
new territory walkers in the Peak
District to sunbathers at Dodgers
reservoirs and in Wales where people are
still being asked to work from home and
only travel when necessary police issued
fines to those not making essential
journeys they were stopping vehicles
check-in why people are open about what
is pleasing is that in most instances
people are traveling for legitimate
purposes and we realize this is very
difficult time for the public but they
are very supportive of us and understand
why we are doing this
but across England lockdown rules were
certainly put to the test
after weeks of life indoors many enjoyed
the freedom the start of this new normal
some however with little care of a
deadly second way into my machine Sky
News